as a closeted gay boy in high school it
was my dream to try Jessica Simpson's
edible makeup line this is literally the
most exciting moment of my life I've
been waiting four years to do this
another school mile or anything but I
have a good pop culture celebrity blog
when I was like 12
am i a pop culture junkie I think the
outsider I would be I've been working at
BuzzFeed for almost ten years I was a
big keeping up with the Kardashian and
back in like 2007 2008 I did own three
bondage hats and I bought them because
Britney Spears wore that George Foreman
grill that's the number one celebrity
product like I just love all things
living in pop culture we're the pimp
juice Oh got some good old pimp juice
hip juice is iconic I mean it's Nelly
nellyville' a hot in her huh and it's
just gonna make me hunt oh yeah exactly
like Red Bull it does that is like so
Lenin news-dot-com wonder if that don't
mean I was expecting carbonation but I
it's not I just don't get why they
didn't carbonate it like it makes no
sense because I'm garbage I don't hate
it
honestly this is really good
this is intimidating why does it look
like cat food
so it's pudding oh wait Stallone oh my
god okay so that's start what are you up
to
it's truly delicious satisfying and
guilt-free who wouldn't want to eat
anything out of this candy this is like
oh they're consistent like the real
Pierce it's a little skin it just like
doesn't look like people should be
eating this it's like oh we're gonna get
sick or you're just gonna get swole
there's some chalkiness it made my mouth
instantly dry post-workout pudding says
mmm to solve all of our problems dream
come true Jessica Simpson's edible
makeup line sexy girls have dessert oh
my goodness who is responsible for this
are you dessert girl dessert girls
aren't afraid to heat it up shake it up
be a flirt put it out there and flaunt
it yes look at the shimmer
[Music]
come I'm like I want this all over my so
this is like a sex cream racist sex
cream okay Jessica Simpson made sex
cream in 2004 hey I'm taking advantage
this is my dream come true
this is like 16 year old gay maybe
freaking out right now yo what was a
courageous huh Jessica Simpson by far
they need to start making this again the
only product I would see myself using
ever again would probably be pimp juice
I'm gonna go with em juice delicious I
gotta say I was a fan of the pimp juice
I wasn't being a pimp juice - yeah I
think the pimp juice is the winner
hey call me a sucker but it's on TV I
want to buy it and so I'm gonna buy
anything that is celeb case in point you
are you have a case in point and you
smell great
I smell so
[Music]
you